[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance
let me apologize again to the world
particularly to the United Kingdom on
behalf of the United States of America
Donald Trump is not of sound mind we are
working to correct the problem as soon
as possible
amid all that he creates mass confusion
charges of corruption hints at collusion
there is a stark reality in almost any
other job in this country assuredly in
any other private-sector job no matter
the financial cost no matter the
upheaval no matter the blowback Donald
Trump our national embarrassment our
international disgrace would have been
fired by now his complete incompetence
his complete failure and his complete
inability to see his incompetence and
his failure as anything except personal
brilliance would get him fired
everywhere from the boardroom at
Microsoft to the deep fryer at
McDonald's at least seven dead and 48
wounded in terror attack and Mayor of
London says there is no reason to be
alarmed the Mayor of London did not say
that Londoners will see an increased
police presence today and over the
course of the next few days no reason to
be alarmed
one of the things the police and all of
us need to do is make sure we're as safe
as we possibly can be Mayor Khan was
urging Londoners not to be alarmed at
additional police presence Trump
proclaimed himself the law and order
candidate he is symbolized by additional
police presence he is in agreement with
mayor Khan but Donald Trump is not the
kind of man who will take yes for an
answer he is now doubled down on his
delusion pathetic excuse by London Mayor
said ich kann who had to think fast on
his no reason to be alarmed statement
MSM is working hard to sell it simply
this is a lie mayor Khan's statement was
made complete before Trump's reaction to
it was made Trump took a part of it out
of context and is now lying to imply
that the part about the police presence
came separately it did not Trump his
lying it may be a lie that is explained
by the liars inability to admit he was
wrong or to understand
next or to process reality as opposed to
what he wants to have had happen but it
is still a lie Trump must confound
contradict exploit boast insult and he
has to do it
so compulsively when he cannot even see
when somebody from the outside his tiny
self-obsessed world is in agreement with
him for that kind of knee-jerk thinking
the lunchroom manager of a middle school
would be fired
do you notice we are not having a gun
debate right now that's because they use
knives and a truck what a London Bridge
kind of attack here in America where
terrorists can easily buy American guns
and rifles and have bought American guns
and rifles and have killed Americans
with American guns and rifles that kind
of terrorist attack would not see men
jumping out of a van brandishing knives
they would be carrying automatic weapons
and mowing down Americans with guns and
rifles bought in America for behavior
that obstinate that slow-witted that
overflowing with bad guesswork an
attorney that any law firm in this
country would be fired we need to be
smart vigilant and tough we need the
courts to give us back our rights we
need the travel ban as an extra level of
safety Trump sent that tweet about 48
hours after Justice Department attorneys
went to the Supreme Court and asked them
to overrule lower courts and in state
Trump's new regulations on foreigners
entering this country and the central
premise of their argument is that it is
not a travel ban and Trump not only
publicly cuts their legs out from under
them but reminds the Supreme Court
justices that one of the reasons the
travel ban was stopped by the other
judges was that while the lawyers
insisted it was not religious based nor
a travel ban Trump and his associates
made and kept making public comments
about how it was religious based and it
was a travel ban and then he doubled
down on this people the lawyers and the
courts can call it whatever they want
but I am calling it what we need and
what it is a travel ban were he the head
of a company that had decided upon a
vital policy and a strategy to defend
policy legally and he had acted so
contradictorily and destructively to
that policy the CEO of any fortune 500
corporation in this country would be
fired despite the constant negative
press CoV fe FB those of us who are
repelled by this man got a rare laugh at
that absurdly meaningless stupid
tweeting mistake but meanwhile Trump and
his littlest flying monkey Sean Spicer
actually tried to seriously claim that
with some kind of brilliant
communications strategy intended perhaps
to distract and confound his critics but
neither side fully understood the
nightmare behind all this the man acting
as the President of the United States
went to his favorite platform of Public
Communication at 1206 a.m. prevailing
local time got to the forty-third
character and the sixth word of a tweet
misspelled something probably the word
coverage and somehow managed to hit Send
the meaninglessness the lack of focus
the carelessness the self-pity the
irresponsible redefinition of a language
itself that has symbolized this
fifth-rate administration from the
moment of Trump's inaugural address
onwards was summarized in five words
plus some kind of typographical error
and no great leap of imagination is
required to presume that it was
disseminated because just as he
misspelled coverage he suddenly phone in
hand fell asleep or otherwise lost
awareness and pressed send or reached
for delete and instead hit Send and then
fell asleep or otherwise screwed up and
checked out then Trump said nothing
about this remarkable and sudden
disconnect from reality for six hours
and when something was finally said it
was a lie a kindergartner wouldn't
believe and the context is lost as well
just two nights earlier he had tweeted
the fake news media works hard at
disparaging and demeaning my use of
social media because they don't want
America to hear the real story evidently
that real story is cough FA for behavior
that irresponsible that incoherent that
utterly self unaware any employee in any
company or in any branch of government
service that was not the presidency
would either be fired were immediately
tested for substance abuse or for their
psychological health or both for more
than a year I have anguished over what's
wrong with Donald Trump's stupidity
madness evil disease injury
I no longer care which attacking a mayor
who agreed with him
attacking him again and in so doing
attacking the city still reeling from a
terrorist attack insisting on a travel
ban while his lawyers are trying to
convince the Supreme Court it is not a
travel ban announcing he doesn't care
what the lawyers call it and threatening
the courts tweeting gibberish while
half-asleep were half conscious or half
sane this is not about policy it is not
about conservatives versus liberals it
is not about Republicans versus
Democrats it is not about make America
great again or grab them by the [ __ ] it
is not about Russia and it is not about
Pittsburgh or Paris or both it is about
absolute baseline incompetence we all
know that we have occupying the office
of the President of the United States a
man doing the simple easy isolated
no-brainer parts of the job so badly so
strangely
so destructively even to his own
perverse goals that were he in any other
job in this country somebody would have
fallen back on Trump's hackneyed
television catchphrase they would have
invoked that nitwit 'add blurt that made
him famous too many infamous to others
and plausible too just enough of this
country and we would be freed from this
self-perpetuating nightmare of a chief
executive who cannot even handle Twitter
let alone reality resist peace